There is something very appealing and attractive
about not caring.
A disregard for consequence and judgment.
A calm, cool collectedness that sets the individual
free.
The truth is, it’s not realistic, nor is
it healthy or practical to not care at all
about anything.
We are all wired to care about things in order
to survive and connect to life.
Even those who appear to not care at all,
still care.
But there is, however, a certain amount of
not caring that is realistic, healthy, and
practical.
A way to frame your perspective so that you
care about the right things the right amount.
No more, no less.
That is the goal.
To care, but not too much.
We should care about our self, our passions,
our loved ones, and life in general.
Life is inexplicably beautiful and there’s
nothing else to do with it other than squeeze
it for all it is worth.
But yet, at the same time, life is immensely
complicated and uncertain.
And it is fundamentally indifferent to how
much you care about it.
So we should not care too much about life’s
imperfections, including our own.
Or the little things that seem far worse in
the moment but never really end up affecting
anything.
Or the things that go wrong or not as planned,
even when we try our best.
Because no matter how much we try.
No matter how much we want or don’t want
something.
No matter how fair or unfair.
Life will never go exactly how we always want
it to.
And so, the trick is that we take like serious
enough to still be motivated to participate
in it and appreciate it.
To pursue our passions, goals, and a healthy,
fulfilling life.
But not take it so serious that we forget
to admit that failure and imperfection are
inevitable.
That trial and tribulation are synonymous
with life.
To feel the pains of life, but to let things
quickly scab up, heel over and then move on.
To refrain from dwelling and picking at the
scab.
To practice forgiveness for the self and forgiveness
for others.
To learn and grow from hardship, and come
out on the other side.
Inevitably, life is going to smack you around,
at least a little bit.
You are going to make mistakes, experience
failure and tragedy, receive negative feedback
and so on.
But by taking life a little less serious,
understanding and sympathizing with the idea
that life in the universe is vastly complex
and random, you will not break under such
pressures.
Things might be hard and things might hurt
at times, but they will not break you.
And better yet, they will build and strengthen
you.
Your are like a muscle in the body.
The more pressure and stress you are able
to withstand without breaking, the stronger
and more powerful you become.
If you can recognize the balance of taking
things seriously, but not too much, you will
be able to more easily withstand life’s
weight.
You will find yourself becoming more and more
calm, resilient, and ultimately successful.
Because those who truly succeed and care about
life, recognize that sometimes caring too
much about life, ruins it.